my priority is to deliver brexit and to
do so in an orderly way that does not
disrupt people's lives so I continue to
believe we need to leave the European
Union with a deal as soon as possible
and of course this house has voted
repeatedly to avoid a No Deal yet
despite the efforts of members on all
sides we have not so far been able to
vote for a deal so ahead of the council
I wrote to president tusk to seek a
short extension to the article 50 period
to the 30th of June critically I also
requested that any extension should be
terminable so that whenever this house
agrees a deal and ratifies the
withdrawal agreement we can get on and
leave and I did this not merely to avoid
a further delay beyond ratification of
the withdrawal agreement but
specifically to retain our ability to
leave the EU without having to hold
European parliamentary elections on the
23rd of May mr. speaker the discussions
at the council were difficult and
unsurprisingly many of our European
partners share the deep frustration that
I know so many of us feel in this house
over the current impasse there was a
range of views about the length of an
extension with a large number of member
states preferring a longer extension to
the end of this year or even into the
next in the end what was agreed by the
UK and the eu-27 was a compromise an
extension lasting until the end of
October the council also agreed that we
would update on our progress at the next
meeting in June critically as I
requested the council agreed that this
extension could be terminated when the
withdrawal agreement has been ratified
so for example if we were to pass a deal
by the 22nd of May we would not have to
take part in European elections and when
the EU has also ratified we will be able
to leave at 11 p.m. on the 31st of May
in short the date of our departure from
the EU and our participation in the
European parliamentary elections remains
a decision for this house as president
tusk said last night during this time
the course of action will be entirely in
the UK's hands in agreeing this
extension there was some discussion in
the council about whether stringent
require the conditions should be imposed
on the you
okay for its EU membership during this
period but I argued against this I put
the case that there is only a single
tier of EU membership with no
conditionality attached beyond existing
treaty obligations the council
conclusions are clear that during the
course of the extension the UK will
continue to hold full membership rights
in turn I assured my fellow leaders that
the UK will continue to be bound by all
our ongoing obligations as a Member
State including the duty of sincere
cooperation the United Kingdom plays a
responsible and constructive role on the
world stage
and we always will that is the kind of
country we are the choices we face the
choices we face our stock and the
timetable is clear I believe we must now
press on at Pace with our efforts to
reach a consensus on a deal that is in
the national interest I welcome the
discussions that have taken place with
the opposition in recent days and the
further talks which are resuming today
this is not the normal way of British
politics and it is uncomfortable for
many in both the government and
opposition parties reaching an agreement
will not be easy because to be
successful it will require both sides to
make compromises
but however challenging but however
challenging it may be politically i
profoundly believe that in this unique
situation where the house is deadlocked
it is incumbent on both front benches to
seek to work together to deliver what
the British people voted for and I think
that the British people expect their
politicians to do just that when the
national interest demands it I hope that
we can reach an agreement on a single
unified approach that we can put to the
house for approval but if we cannot do
so soon then we will seek to agree a
small number of options for the future
relationship that we will put to the
house in a series of votes to determine
which course to pursue and as I have
made clear before the government stands
ready to abide by the decision of the
house but to make this process work the
opposition would need to agree to this -
with the houses consent we could also
bring forward the withdrawal agreement
bill which is unnecessary
of any deal which ever course we take
this bill will take time to pass through
both houses so if we want to get on with
leaving we need to start this process
soon and it could also provide a useful
forum to resolve some of the outstanding
issues in the future relationship
crucially mr. speaker any agreement on
the future relationship may involve a
number of additions and clarifications
to the political declaration so I'm
pleased that at this council all 27
member states responded to my update on
the ongoing cross-party talks by
agreeing that the European Council is
prepared to reconsider the political
declaration on the future relationship
in accordance with the positions and
principles stated in its guidelines and
statements the council also reiterated
that the withdrawal agreement itself
could not be reopened
Mr Speaker I know the whole country is
intensely frustrated that this process
to leave the European Union has not
still been completed I never wanted to
seek this extension and I deeply regret
that we have not yet been able to secure
agreement in this house for a deal that
would allow us to leave in a smooth and
orderly way I know too that this whole
debate is putting members on all sides
of the house under immense pressure and
causing uncertainty across the country
and we need to resolve this so let's use
the opportunity of the recess to reflect
on the decisions that will have to be
made swiftly on our return after Easter
and let us then resolve to find a way
through the sand paths so that we can
leave the European Union with the deal
as soon as possible so that we can avoid
having to hold those European
parliamentary elections and above all so
that we can fulfill the democratic
decision of the referendum deliver
brexit and move our country forward this
is our national duty as elected members
of this house and nothing today is more
pressing or more vital and I commend
this statement to the house
[Applause]